our young applications deployed in
hybrid and multi cloud environments and
those can help you modernize your
existing apps building new ones and run
them anywhere securely stay tuned to
learn how to get started with anthos
[Music]
welcome to you and those 101 today we
will show you how easy it is to get
started with anthos let's create our
first and those deployment in the Google
Cloud console select a project you want
to work in or create a new one in the
left navigation menu select anthos
enable the API this may take a few
seconds but when done you will see the
main landing page in the getting started
section you can read the documentation
create and register your clusters and
launch enter sample deployment this is
what we are going to do today so click
and launch now on the deployment
configuration screen you can select an
existing service account but since this
is a demo we will just create a new
service account leave the service
account name and ID as defaults and add
a description and click deploy while the
deployment is progressing the cloud
console transitions to the deployment
manager view and after the sample is
deployed in a few minutes you will see a
green check mark and can review the full
deployment you should see a list of all
enabled resources including the two and
those gke clusters for prod and non prod
and one compute engine instance for the
jump server and that's it
you just deployed a sample app in endows
when you go back to the Endo's dashboard
you see service mesh card and cluster
status card cluster status is green
indicating that the clusters are healthy
you can click on each cluster and know
more about them by navigating to anthos
GGA within the clusters we can see the
nodes and inside each node we can see
the power summary and the details in the
workload section you can see what loads
across all clusters under services and
ingress section we have the sto ingress
gate
we service for the Anto sample cluster 1
and ingress gateway manages inbound
traffic for your application service
mesh and if we click on the external
endpoint using port 80 we see our
deployed application in production now
if we switch back to the Antos and click
on the service mesh card we see all our
services in the table view we can also
switch to topology graph and those
service mesh automatically observes
which services are communicating with
each other to show service to service
connection details you can even drag and
zoom or hover over services to see
additional details including outbound
UPS you can click on any service to
create SL o--'s let's say we want to
create an availability SLO where our
shopping cart service is 99% available
during a month
there are SLO is set up alright so we
just deployed an e-commerce application
using an tow sample deployment let's
quickly review the different components
that we have deployed there are two
Antos gke clusters running on Google
cloud and those sample cluster 1 and
sample cluster 2 and the anthos service
mesh deployed as separate service meshes
running on both clusters we also have
separate instances of the online
boutique application deployed and
running on both clusters this is a
web-based e-commerce app that uses a
number of micro services written in
various programming languages including
Java Go Python and JavaScript and we had
a compute engine instance used as a jump
server for accessing resources in our
project in both clusters and applying
those changes what are you waiting for
start your Antos journey today using
sample deployment as well as the
resources linked below and let us know
how it goes in the comments section and
for more anthers and google cloud
content don't forget to Like and
subscribe to our Channel
you
[Music]